Russians are voting in local elections
this weekend in the run-up there's been
a series of standoffs between Moscow
police and protesters these
demonstrators want free and fair
elections and they accuse the government
of keeping opposition candidates off the
ballots now elections are being held
across the country on Sunday in 19
regions and critics say this vote will
not be free or fair because as in Moscow
local governments have the last word on
who makes the final list of candidates
officially sanctioned candidates have
had no trouble securing their slots on
the ballot but those opposed to the
Russian government have often been
silenced yes main [ __ ] me is furious
together with thousands of others she
signed her name in support of a social
Liberal candidate in Moscow's upcoming
local elections but then the Electoral
Commission decreed that the candidate
was not allowed to stand we weren't
given an explanation
they just said that's not your signature
that was it sure it was an arbitrary
decision she says and it spurred her
into action she spoke to independent
media and then like tens of thousands of
others took to the streets and
authorized and unauthorised
demonstrations security personnel have
regularly come down heavily on the
protesters and thousands have been
arrested I went on the demos to show
that I was against what was happening I
want to influence how people live in our
city she's especially concerned about
the area where her family has lived for
four generations the gagarin district
yes many volunteers in the district
offices and that's where she met Jelena
Rosa Cova
the election candidate who owing to
allegedly forged signatures was forced
to step down
rusik over took a case to court but in
vain there is a group of people who make
all the important decisions and they
don't want change
the most connector Martine it is she
says all about keeping the status quo
Moscow's Electoral Commission says it's
familiar with such arguments but seems
unable or unwilling to do anything just
a snap on you let me in the room right
now I can't see any reason to call off
the elections if we see problems like
those in other regions then we'll act
accordingly the local elections in
Moscow have developed into a serious
political crisis and although the
opposition Bailey has a chance he has
man [ __ ] me sir she's not giving up the
only table one euro
I'll continue to fight and take part in
demos all of this is leading to the
degradation of our society I don't want
that especially not for her children she
says she hopes that they might have the
chance of one day living in a democratic
Russia